so I just got back from my second lost
caverns of Exelon pre-release and first
of all I should say the set rocks The
Limited environment rocks it is super
cool layered complex all these things um
but I think more than any other set it
makes me understand the point of a core
set see I started playing Magic about 12
years ago and my first sets were in
inrad Block return to Rica block and
Theos block and it's not that these sets
were easy easy but the floor was low
enough where they didn't feel that
different than a core set you know you
could pick something that wasn't too
hard it felt pretty similar to something
you might pick in a core set LCI on the
other hand is bananas there's so many
random little synergies descend and
craft are both really cool but complex
mechanics and even dinosaur is the
easiest archetype still feels like it
has a lot to juggle for a new player I
have to imagine it's just kind of a lot